and you wrote the book rational optimist
obviously that has been coming a global
bestseller I've read it and the main
takeaway from it was just hey like you
can actually benefit from being positive
on the future of the world so it's
interesting to hear maybe not pessimism
from you but but a lower degree of
optimism when it comes to some of the
political stuff maybe talk a little bit
about like that framework applied to
today's society you know we live in the
safest most prosperous time in human
history except for if you read headlines
and then if it doesn't may not feel that
way so kind of how do you after writing
the book think about you know current
events today and where the world really
is well setting aside democratic
politics for a minute in every other
respect I think the rational optimist
was bang on and is completely right and
I still adhere to all its its claims
because most of it is about the economic
and medical and other prosperities that
we are experiencing and have been
experiencing and the process of the
processes that have been producing those
improvements in our lifespan health
income our escape from poverty all these
kind of things are continuing there's no
reason to see any diminution in fact it
has been a spectacular decade in that
respect so compared with ten years ago
the average Ethiopian now owns twice as
much money on average that's pretty
remarkable and that's true through
throughout a lot of Africa now when I
was publishing the rational optimist ten
years ago people would quite often say
to me yeah I can see that Asia has made
an escape from poverty but Africa can't
possibly follow can it I mean it's bound
to stay extremely poor forever and I
would say no I don't think so and I
think I'm being proven right on that
sort of kind of thing I wrote the book
during the Great Recession of the
financial crisis of 2008 to ten and that
felt like a possible end of the good
times and the
beginning of the bad times and a lot of
people told me it was but I said no I
think we will get the show back on the
road I think we will be able to improve
people's living standards in the years
ahead and then along came the euro
crisis the war in Ukraine the war in
Syria the Ebola epidemic you know the
world everywhere I went in the last
decade there was always a reason for
somebody to say to me you can't still be
a rational optimist given what's
happening X around the world and yet as
I say this has been an extraordinary
decade there's a really beautiful
experiment that Hans Rosling did whose
fellow optimist sadly who died but who
was one of the pioneers of this kind of
thinking swedish health economists and
what he did was he asked a thousand
people in the last 20 years has the
percentage of the world population that
lives in extreme poverty that's a dollar
ninety a day or less doubled half or
stayed the same in those 20 years and in
the u.s. sixty-five percent of people
said it has doubled five percent said it
had hard the five percent were right the
65 percent were wrong that's pretty
striking
but what Rosling then did was he said if
I had written those three answers on
three bananas and thrown the three
bananas into a cage with a chimpanzee in
it the chimpanzee would have picked up
the right answer 33 percent of the time
not 5 percent of the time it would have
done six times as well as human beings
in answering a question about human
society so what's the problem here the
problem is not that we don't know what's
going on in the world it's that we know
things that are not true we're
absolutely convinced of things that
actually are not true
and that seems to me a growing problem
that largely because of media coverage
of negative events which is always
happened but is becoming more extreme
all the time that's because of that we
end up with a strong impression that
things are going wrong in the world
and we don't know that they're going
right interestingly when we look at our
own lives we're quite optimistic and why
is that because the media doesn't cover
your own life and it feels like that
media coverage how much of it is kind of
the fake news disinformation what I'll
call kind of complicit type of coverage
versus maybe they're actually just
sharing individual stories and those
individual stories give the reader
listener or watcher the feeling that oh
this must be everyone else's story right
there's kind of you know a divergence
there in my opinion of like some of it
is very intentional that leads to what
this thought process your talk about and
then some of it feels like they're just
telling the story of the person that's
in extreme poverty and because that's
the only story they tell and they don't
bounce it with the story of the person
who got out of extreme poverty we then
think oh everyone you know maybe that
way is that makes sense
yeah now I think it's it's it's largely
a matter of omission not commission in
other words I don't think the
journalists are going out there saying I
want to tell fibs to the world about how
bad things are what they are doing is
responding to reader interest in
negative stories and you can do the
experiments I mean it's apparent to be
done to say you know choose an article
to read out because this is a experiment
on comprehension and pronunciation
actually it isn't it's a an experiment
to see which articles you choose people
choose the negative articles so you know
I'm afraid bad news
does sell good news is no news if it
bleeds it leads as they say in the
journalism industry so it's it's largely
a matter of the fact that you know just
think about it you know a war-torn
country that is in the in the in the
news for a year after year after year
Angola say or Mozambique in my youth you
know yet another report from this
terrible war where thousands of people
are being maimed by landmines and you
know
there's been another attempt at peace
talks which has broken down these kind
of things came out of African countries
all my life sort of thing the Congo
Nigeria
you know countries were in the news
because things were going badly there
and then suddenly you notice one day you
know what Angola is never in the news
these days and when you notice that go
and look up what's happening in Angola
and it's usually because actually the
peace treaty did stick economic growth
is occurring the number of people in
extreme poverty is declining hunger is
on the retreat so it it really is the
fact that the news focus moves away as
soon as things start going right and
that seems a pity every now and then you
get a color piece saying you know
actually life's looking up for the
average Angolan no I'm I'm take pulling
that one off the shelf I don't know if
there's peace and light in Angola at the
moment but I suspect it's a heck of a
lot better than it was 20 years ago and
just the statistics bear this out by the
way Steven Pinker you know has
chronicled the decline of violence and
warfare and he points out that we've I
think we've now got either 10 or 11 Wars
going on in the world right that sounds
like a lot it's the lowest number we've
ever had in recorded history
and none of those are happening in the
Western Hemisphere there's not one going
on in Latin America which there was
until a few years ago so that's never
happened before we know how to whole
hemisphere with no war in it so let's
let's appreciate that things aren't as
bad as we'd like to think